on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood on uncensored
tonight London wax drivers with a daily
charge the critics call a war on
motorists from gas stove bands in New
York to electric car mandates across
Europe can our poorest pay the bill for
tackling climate change and should they
have to
the UK's foreign secretary heads for
China to reset strained relations as a
slew of U.S officials who criticized for
bending the knee to G but aren't we
supposed to keep our enemies close we'll
debate that
class as police are told to ditch the
rainbow helmets and get back to policing
should coppers be fighting culture wars
or sticking to fighting crime
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood good evening welcome to
Piers morganland center with me Rosanna
Lockwood in the chair for peers tonight
now our Capital City London is now the
world's largest low emissions Zone I
think that's something to be proud of
but I know many of you think otherwise
I'm talking of course about mayor Sadiq
Khan's expansion of Euless today costing
drivers of older vehicles non-compliant
ones at least 12 pounds 50 extra to move
around the city every day painful yes
horribly painful for some but that's how
deterrence work and this whole thing has
become about more than just air quality
traffic cameras and London it's become
about money privilege and hypocrisy in
this Brave New Euless world you're
either pro-motorist or anti-motorist
which means you're either on the side of
hard-working Ordinary People or you're
not
we know that people in power who make
unpopular decisions about the way we
live often take planes and they get
driven around in big cars in order to do
their jobs they are not struggling to
get to work or running a small business
and we want to see them suffer too to
practice what they preach which they're
telling us to do what they're
legislating us to do
and we could actually insist on that in
the way that we vote we could choose the
leader that uses a bicycle and wears
hemp clothing but for many reasons many
of us don't we could also insist the
cost of tackling climate change gets
heat Less on ordinary people and more on
those still profiting from the stuff
that is causing all of this fossil fuels
that would be very worthwhile but again
we don't do that so instead we have to
sit with the fact that sometimes in life
difficult decisions will be made for us
by the people we put into Power
decisions about our health and our
future and we should be reminded of and
aware of our privilege to shout about
these decisions as loud as we want which
is going on at the moment very much so
with you Les and we have the power to
vote differently next time if we so
choose and we should remember that some
people in other countries would
seriously Envy us that and I think that
is something else we can be proud of
well joining me to debate the cost of
the climate crisis policy director of
the Grantham Institute on climate change
Bob Ward and talk TV presenter Richard
Tice in the studio down the line
Professor Judith Perry climatologist and
author of the book climate uncertainty
and risk rethinking our response thank
you all three of you Richard I'll come
straight to you I know this is a topic
close to your heart and you've been down
there at some of the protests today
around you let and you and I do not
agree on this topic yeah sure look the
question is does London have a toxic air
problem and a simple answer is no the
quality of London's air is the best it's
ever been according to who according to
everybody who looks at this according to
the World Health Organization we've got
our city of London is in the best 25 of
cities around the world the data clearly
shows at the roadside across most of
London we are within World Health
Organization guidelines the only area
where it's toxic Rosanna that everybody
seems to forget yourself included is the
tube where it is brutally unhealthy of
course it's unhealthy on the tube it's a
Victorian infrastructure but if we all
appreciate you look at the World Health
Organization data I've used the monitors
the meters you walk around London's
roads and particularly in outer London
and we are below the who guidelines we
don't have an air pollution Problem in
London with all due respect I will come
to you Bob because I can see you're
shaking your head with all due respect
Richard you're a politician and a
businessman but not a scientist so we
will come to the science expert shortly
on this but on the politics side I'm
interested to know why you're pegging
your political movement so much to this
when there has been so much polling that
shows a lot of Brits actually really do
care about climate change and they want
to see the conservative don't confuse
London's air quality with climate change
it's a completely different point you're
talking about what is the quality of
London's air it's the best it's ever
been I'll tell you why because this is
what people care about in London and
this is a tax grab on the poorest the
least well-off small businesses in
London because that's the point and you
don't seem to care about that of course
I do of course I do Richard the cash
grab point I want to come to Bob on
shortly but it is about climate change
because emissions necessarily fit into
it it's about the air quality in London
it's the data right and the data shows
we're within the World Health
Organization
go ahead Bob yeah so what Richard's
saying is completely untrue
the air is monitored by a group at uh
Imperial College London the last set of
data was for 2020 so remember it was a
year when we had uh the lockdown in
London there was not a single site
across London where the levels of
particulate matter and of nitrogen
dioxide the two main air pollutants were
below the uh the limits set by the World
Health Organization which is 20
micrograms for nitrogen dioxide so it's
completely untrue to say that the air in
London is fit to breathe it is
dangerously High has it ever been has it
ever been better than it is
down you're right shut me down you claim
that the air was within who and it is
that is completely it is I've been
around with the meters it says it's
healthy Richard you and a meter is not a
scientist yes
because I'm not a scientists
Richard you have to have the meter stay
in the same place and you've got to
measure them over a year you can't just
wander around during the afternoon and
think I'm doing science this is the
answer it just doesn't work that way
Richard so how does it work how does it
work when you do it day after day
quality Network they are the experts
they publish the data go and have a look
and has it has it ever been best
it's above the who limits we have
somebody else in this discussion Judas
she's listening into all of this Judith
you take a slightly different view I
know from Bob in terms of the climate
emergency but do you think Euless is
warranted
um well this is just classic seeing this
disagreement both statements from both
sides have elements of truth but both
are wrong and not recognizing the other
side so what you have when the facts are
disputed and the interpretations of of
the evidence disagree will you try to
find common ground you focus on you know
what are some sensible policies without
having to rely on agreeing on you know
uncertain facts and you know the climate
change issue is this in Space the US is
a microcosm of this disagreement but
with regards to climate change we have
to recognize that we have the climate
crisis isn't what it used to be even a
few years ago
the worst emissions scenarios are now
off the table
the UN Conference of the parties are now
working off of a 2.5 to degrees
Centigrade warming by the end of the
21st century and we've already worn by
1.2 degrees
the ipcc admits that the climate models
are running too hot
recent estimates of the climate
sensitivity to carbon dioxide are
increasingly lower but the biggest
problem is we've confounded the slow
creep of warming with extreme weather
events the extreme weather events that
we're seeing have little to no
relationship with the slow creep of
global warming so we need to
okay thank you
um I love the topic of climate change
it's so interesting but it is also so
confounding because you've got three
people four people in fact in this
conversation coming at it from all sorts
of different angles and people saying
this data no that's wrong this data
that's wrong Bob is shaking his head now
to what you were saying with regards to
warming and I know that in terms of the
way the climate scientists stand on this
issue you are somewhat of an outlier in
this aren't you
uh not really what I have to say is well
within the framework of the ipcc
assessment report it is not within the
framework of all the alarming rhetoric
coming from the U.N
journalists and alarmists politicians
and environmental advocacy groups I mean
we have a deeply complex highly
uncertain issue that we're trying to
deal with and the over simplistic story
that were being fed by U.N officials and
by activists and Advocates is just
misleading us into a bad direction for
urgently implementing policies why that
could why what's the what's the what's
the scheme the strategy to do that
okay this goes back decades into you
know there's a world view from the U.N
environmental program back in the 1980s
and 1990s
you know about degrowth anti-capitalism
and so on so there's a world view that
likes this
um and very early on in all this in 1992
we had a treaty an international treaty
to prevent dangerous human-caused
climate change by eliminating fossil
fuels before we had
any evidence of unusual warming so the
policy card has been way out in front of
the scientific course from the very
beginning on it they need to step back
and rethink all this thank you Judith
Bob uh go on your thoughts
well uh Judith has told an amusing
revisionist history of the science of
climate change
um the fact that we are on a lower uh
temperature path is down to the fact
that many countries are now cutting
their emissions and so we are seeing
that the movement is towards uh lower
emissions in many countries including
the UK UK has reduced its emissions
greatly uh since 1990 we need the
Emerging Market in developing countries
countries like China to reduce their
emissions now so that's good good thing
but we're nowhere near on a safe path
and due to Judy is incredibly talking
from the United States at the moment
there's a big hurricane out in the Gulf
of Mexico which they're expecting to
develop and intensify rapidly before it
hits land in Florida
a link to the fact that the sea surface
temperatures in the Gulf of Mexico now
are very high and they're very high
because the Earth is warming and Judy is
saying oh well it's got nothing to do
with uh extreme weather
I am a real genuine expert on the issue
of hurricanes I forecast them in my
company I'm an expert on the climate
dynamics of hurricanes there is nothing
unusual going on with the hurricane in
the Gulf of Mexico I'm afraid
there you have one agreed with the
American the American Scientific
establishment she's out on her own
I agree with the statements made by the
NOAA gfdl statement on hurricanes and
climate change okay it's completely yes
I know there's no link between rapid
intensification and climate change
this is really important scientists
disagree with each other yeah which
allows a vacuum for people to know it
allows debate and discussion
on the ipcc did not find any evidence of
an increase in intensity in the
observational record or an increase in
Rapid intensification Judy have you
published your have you published your
paper explaining that there is no link
between the rapid intensification of
hurricanes and climate change
uh I am citing right now I do
fundamental research on this I am citing
the ipcc and the World Meteorological
organization assessments you are off no
I'm not I'm not I'm citing exactly what
the literature says Judy and as you know
you've not published anything that has
shown that there is no link between
intensification and climate change that
this has been a
a brilliant example of why this debate
is not going away why is such a heated
issue even over these new LEDs cameras
here in London because you know as
Richard yes you point out there is not
consensus on this issue that's why we're
having this debate that's why I'm open
to hearing all sides that's why we must
always have these debates and we must
not be smeared and labeled but you have
to tell them yeah you absolutely and you
haven't told me the truth you haven't
told them you haven't admitted that
London's air quality is the best it's
ever been asked me a simple question
still dangerous and it's still above
that's a simple question if you pay 12
pounds 50 right to drive your car in the
new uh Euless extended zone right how is
that going to help change the the uh
that's the principle so you don't care
about the poor yourself I'm selfish
you're so rich you don't care about the
problems
you can't tell the truth and you lose
the yard poor people poor people can't
afford a 20 or 30 grand car that's 2 000
Scrappers
whatsoever scrappage scheme should be
more generous and it should be the
government coming in and helping there's
no such thing as government money it's
all our money it's taxpayers money
London's air quality
I think wealthy people shouting that you
know other people I don't care about the
poor people
those who can't afford it results that's
what he's just admitted no we have to
wrap it up there we have a lot more
coming on the show gentlemen and Judas
uh down the line with us as well this
has been fascinating knew it was going
to be spicy thanks so much not sure
without consensus not sure if we ever
will but we have had a discussion
haven't we uncensored next as the
British foreign secretary heads to
Beijing to reset relations with China we
ask if any bending the need to
presidency is fought with date
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
TV's very own Piers Morgan uncensored is
nominated in the brand new TV interview
category at this year's National
Television Awards best TV interview of
course he's up for it it's probably all
those exclusive interviews with the
likes of Cristiano Ronaldo they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed Donald Trump I believe it was a
free and fair election then you're a
fool Kanye West I'm simply going to
challenge you interview adjourned have I
forgotten anyone wake up people
I mean he does get some good interviews
it has to be said prime minister Mr
President first lady Stormy Daniels they
have all been fantastic interviews and
if you agree you can vote for peers go
online have your say
nationaltvawards.com but you can also
scan that code vote for peers please get
behind him and vote we know we're new we
know we're different the force behind
talk deserves to win keep it
award-winning Piers Morgan uncensored
vote for him so get online and cast your
vote for peers now give the poor guy a
chance please I beg you good luck peers
good luck Pez let it roll
all right
welcome back to uncensored that has been
announced the British foreign secretary
James cleverley is going to visit China
this week in an attempt to stabilize an
increasingly turbulent relationship he
has promised to raise concerns over
human rights Rising tensions about
Taiwan and the erosion of democracy in
Hong Kong China is of course a major
trading partner but it is increasingly a
geopolitical pariah indeed critics say
any bending of the knee to presidency
sends the wrong message now one of those
critics is former leader of the
conservative party in Duncan Smith Ian
thank you for making time to talk about
this quite simply a trip by cleverly to
China not a good idea in your books why
I think it's a waste of time
um it's interesting because just quite
recently the German foreign minister
came back from a visit to Beijing and
she said when it comes to anything to do
with human rights or social issues all
the terrible things that have happened
genocide Etc they're just not listening
she said it's like talking to I mean in
effect she said it's like talking to a
brick wall they're not giving anything
back that is way too finished and they
only want to talk about the things that
matter to them uh and if you're not
prepared to talk about those then your
meeting is quite short I mean the
problem we've got is we're dealing with
a country is enormously powerful now
we've basically fed it in that
production I I say by the way I should
give it a declaration I am sanctioned by
the Chinese government uh and so are my
family so the reality I have here is
that this is a government that has
committed genocide is committing genus
genocide in xinjiang slave labor
regularly many of the products we buy
are slave labor involved in them they
threaten to invade Taiwan regularly
they've invaded the South China Seas
against the un's edicts they trashed the
sino-british agreement they're arresting
peaceful democracy campaigners they
trash the Christian churches they have
been doing organ harvesting on the falun
gong in China it goes on and on and on
this is a regime that is relevant I
think of the Nazi regime in the 1930s
and we learned then the hard way that
appeasement to organizations like this
simply doesn't work you have to be very
clear and obvious to them that there are
downsides to behavior like this which is
beyond the pale those are some very very
strong words ways to frame it in of
course you're entitled opinion on that
and it's a huge breadth of expertise on
the issue as well you've listed all of
those points there Taiwan the uyghurs
what's happened to Hong Kong as well I
hear all of that I spent the last two
years over on the other side of the
world in Singapore reporting on the
economics of China and Asia as well my
surprise at coming back to this side of
the world is that people don't seem to
be taking it very seriously the threat
of the emergent China in fact it's too
late now it's already emerged but in
terms of it being an economic Force we
can't ignore that it's likely to
overtake the US in the next decade as
the world's largest economic superpower
can we afford to not have a relationship
with it well first of all I don't think
it will uh maybe seven years ago when
people thought it would that was a
possibility but China's economy is now
in a in a real mess to be quite Frank
with you but the key thing here is
you're right uh it's interesting that
you're in Singapore but the reality is
we're not ignoring them what we have to
do is it we need to treat with them on
the basis it says we're not prepared to
bend our need to you or to give you an
inch when it comes to the brutality that
you serve out to those inside China and
outside China and you must abide by
global rules that we all agree to like
the World Trading organization you will
know then at your time at Singapore
China regularly trashes those rules they
subsidize businesses you know the
telecoms industry was massively
subsidized in China Huawei and others
that's why they pretty much got rid of
most of the free worlds Telecom
Communications companies there's no
money in it for them this goes on the
whole time so it's not just in human
rights it's elsewhere too and so I think
it's very important a relation ship with
China as America shows can be done on
the basis where you are very clear and
you sanctioned those officials who
behave appallingly which America has
done which we fail to do in this country
we haven't sanctioned a single person uh
an administrator in Hong Kong for the
trashing of the sign of British
agreement and the brutality of the
meeting out now America's sanctioned 10
and they didn't actually run Hong Kong
and when it comes to xinjiang we've
sanctioned three low officials America
sanction 12 including the most senior so
you know other countries manage to have
a relationship on the basis of robust
direct criticism and we shouldn't shy
from it but we are shying from it when
you lay it out like that it makes me
wonder why we're having this different
type of relationship why the lack of
sanctions if you think they are so
warranted and necessary which I'm
inclined to agree with you on a lot of
those points
um and in terms of that Insight you got
from the German ambassador that went
over and what they found out in terms of
is it any point at all going to the
meeting because what's the UK got to
offer China why would they listen to us
well we've got a lot to offer them
because China's busy with their spies
inside the UK we have a lot of
Technology here we also have a lot of
involvement and links in security and
intelligence with the United States we
are a global player but the problem is
we play ourselves down in these matters
so our universities are inundated now uh
with Chinese post-grad students they're
definitely completely in hawk in terms
of money to them we have the Confucius
Institute now checking up on Chinese
overseas students scaring them out of
debates and meetings they shut down
debates inside some of the universities
when they're critical of China this goes
on here in the UK right now we have a
false police stations Chinese police
stations we had the people being hauled
into the into the compound in Manchester
of the Consular General and beaten up in
front of the police all this stuff tells
you that this is a regime that is very
like the regime in the 1930s what we
have to do is be honest and clear and
straight with them about what is not
acceptable and public and until you
change your ways you simply cannot
cooperate you on the basis that you may
wish to Ian thank you very much for
setting up this conversation for us some
interesting insights there for more on
this now we're going to debate with
China reporter and the author of Beijing
rules Bethany Allen and the author of
The Coming collapse of China and China
is going to walk Gordon Chang both of
you thank you Bethany I'll come to you
first I hope you're listening to those
comments there Brian Duncan Smith
obviously we're coming at this from a
sort of British Viewpoint you're based
in the US you've got a lot of expertise
covering China especially from Taiwan
when you hear all of this do you think
there is any point for the UK to have a
relationship with China
well look I think what we're really
debating here isn't engagement
governments talk to other governments
the world can't function well if that
doesn't happen the problem is that
previous government policy has given
engagement a bad name in the past
engagement was synonymous with with
naivete with giving up on key Democratic
Values uh and interests without getting
anything in return
um this was engagement from a position
of weakness and that is what Britain had
that's what Germany had that's what the
U.S had this belief that we had to give
things up simply to get a meeting that
getting a meeting was enough of a
takeaway and that we didn't really
expect anything in return and if China
promised something we didn't check up on
it we just believed him that is that's a
position of weakness but engagement
talking with Chinese government leaders
from a position of strength can be a
powerful tool and just think about it
that's why the Chinese government pushes
for it in the first place they always
want to talk with people people because
they do it from a position of strength
knowing that they are not going to back
down on their own core interests
and knowing that they can walk away from
a meeting if they need to or if they
want to and I think what uh you know
Britain's mistake has been with China is
is too often approaching uh China alone
and I think that that's something that
uh Boris Johnson began to improve on and
I think that Rishi sunak
um Can can improve on this understanding
that when when you know when cleverly
goes to China if sunok meets with Xi
Jinping next week in India at the G20
that they aren't alone that they have a
growing number of like-minded democrat
Democratic partners and allies on their
side
um who can help back up their demand
back up their statements and back up
their own our own Democratic interests I
mean engagement can be a powerful tool
and I think and it can also be a
powerful tool to prevent the absolute
worst case scenario which is
miscalculation misunderstanding
resulting in a military conflict and as
you know our governments don't talk to
one another they the risk of something
like that happening gets higher and
higher and that's why you know this
debate about dialogue is happening
because if you don't the the results can
be absolutely catastrophic I just want
to bring Gordon into this and Gordon
you've been listening in as well and Ian
was listing out a series of threats he
sees uh not only to us here in the
United Kingdom but other Allied
countries as well how big a threat do
you think China is to the West
China is an existential threat to the
West Xi Jinping has been propagating
this notion that China is the world's
only sovereign state
um and you know you just go on from
there the problem is that when cleverly
goes to Beijing the Chinese are going to
view it as Britain acknowledging its
supplicant status and that's what they
do with American officials the bide
Administration has sent four senior
officials to China without a return
visit from a Chinese official to
Washington so the Chinese say well look
this is like Imperial times where the
vassals come and they acknowledge their
subordinate status and I think that yeah
engagement sounds like it should work
we've been trying it for five decades
it's just created this horrible
situation we got to try something new
because if we don't try something new
things are just going to get worse well
I'm not saying that something new is
going to be better but at least it
guarantees us or at least it gives us
the possibility of success whereas
engagement has totally totally failed so
what other alternative way are you
proposing
well first of all
um we're not going to send anybody to
Beijing if China wants to talk to us
they've got to come to Washington and
also I think that if we don't talk you
know China has this policy of not
talking to Americans for instance well
why don't we adopt the same thing just
not talk to them let them get scared for
a while but also I believe we need to
decouple from China China is closing
itself off from the world Xi Jinping is
engaging in some very belligerent
Behavior I think that as Ian Duncan
Smith said the Chinese economy is
tumbling down that makes Xi Jinping I
think acting in ways which will be
Reckless so we now need to switch to uh
to change our emphasis from talking to
China to starting to defend ourselves
from China Bethany just uh bring you in
on that the idea of decoupling and maybe
just saying look if you want to speak to
us come to DC does that work
well I don't think that works either and
to be clear I think it's incredibly
important that any kind of conversations
any kind of so-called engagement has to
come with tough actions and that's
something that we are seeing from them
by demonstration that and that they're
building on from the Trump
Administration and that's something that
increasingly we've seen from Britain
although I will say in Britain's case
what we've had I think is a a bad
relationship with China but as Ian laid
out not many actual strong moves to
support democratic values and so I think
that there's an opening here for sunac
uh you know to um to have a tougher
policy on China and also talk to the
Chinese and also go to Beijing
um or you know as cleverly is going to
Beijing but but to your to your question
Rosanna about uh about decoupling look
we don't want full decoupling that's not
possible economic decoupling is not
possible and that would it would cause
you know vast poverty around the world
that would greatly increase the risk of
a military conflict between China and
democratic nations however I am strongly
supportive of the idea of a selective
decoupling to promote
um to promote Democratic Values uh so
decoupling from companies that are
deeply complicit in China's
authoritarian and totalitarian state and
also selective decoupling to promote
National Security interests as you know
the UK banned Huawei from its you know
sensitive telecommunications networks
great idea
um and and I also think something we
haven't done that we need to is
increasingly used to have to decoupling
to promote human rights this is
something that we have actually done
very little of with the exception of
sanctioning some individuals which is
symbolic but has no real world effect
Bethany Gordon Ian thank you very much
for your time
thank you uncensored next London's met
police chief says it's time for officers
to stop publicly supporting so-called
work causes is this a return to good
old-fashioned crime fighting or a blow
for social justice
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think there's only one for one
king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail start working just because
their skin folk don't mean their are
Kinfolk do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in some way is an
excuse yeah for at what appear
an abuse of power
when they first got together there were
press stories weighty Katie that would
make her a
bringing the man
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
vote me off sure
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now over the
last few years images like this have
become somewhat familiar when we talk
about police officers across the world
in wealth in the UK met police chief of
Sir Mark Rowley wants to see an end to
it he's saying
black lives matter Pride those types of
events a range of other social and
cultural issues from now on his officers
will be told not to take the knee to not
fly rainbow Flags or wear badges that
support environmental causes so is this
a return to good old-fashioned policing
as some are suggesting or is it a
backwards step to a time when the police
were seen as enemies by some minorities
and marginalized communities here to
discuss all of this former police
officer of 31 years and director of the
Law and Order Foundation Norman Brennan
in Scotland strategic advisor on a
quality diversity and inclusion for
police Scotland and former haringey
police Commander Dr Victor olisa and
from Los Angeles we're joined by former
BLM activist Xavier de Rousseau to talk
about this internationally as well but I
will begin with Norman here in the
studio Norman uh you know you're a
copper of the sort of traditional order
I think I can call you that and you talk
a lot about policing now what do you
make of this move to basically dework
the police force well I fully support
the Met commissioner samart Rowley
um the long and the short is is that
when you join the Police Service you
join to police Auckland communities
you're there for everyone and everyone
there's nobody that you favor in part on
one over another that's why all police
officers must act impartially and we're
told to police without fear or favor so
my main concern is that you should join
the Police Service wear your uniform
stand straight and strident kneel to
nobody Buckle to nobody and the only
time you kneel or Buckle is when you're
saving someone's life who's having a
heart attack or someone that has been
shot or stabbed and you're placing your
hands over to try and save their lives
apart from that where your uniform smart
the same uniform I don't want to see
police vehicles being painted all sorts
of colors and you certainly don't kneel
down to anybody and I think the few
officers that did kneel including one
Chief Constable will never be doing that
again I just want to pick up that point
you've made about without fear or favor
I found that interesting because in
journalism use that phrase a lot being a
good journalist means doing so without
fear or favor but of course yeah
journalists are biased it gets pointed
out a lot everyone has personal biases
police officers on the job they're
professional no doubt many of them are
but they are going to have inbuilt
biases depending on their upbringing or
the way they feel about certain topics
so
there have been complaints throughout
Decades of ethnic minorities saying that
they felt that they weren't treated
fairly by police officers so do you
think any kind of social justice causes
helps that
well to be quite honest of you you say
that many black people I deal with I I
don't look at their color yes they are
black when I grew up in Wembley I was
known as the white black man there was
in my rugby team there were 13 black
players and two white players so I grew
up with the community black community I
went to school with them and I policed
with them and I policed certain areas of
London that were black and you know what
I pleased without fear or favor a black
uh a black robber or a burglar early
hours of the morning stabbed me in the
chest when I tried to arrest him for
committing three armed burglaries he
didn't stab me because I was a white
policeman he stabbed me because he was
trying to get away I didn't arrest him
because he was black I arrested him
because he was a robber so I think
all this all this stuff that we keep in
hearing in the media that the police
pick on black people or gay people or
anybody else there may be a handful but
I promise you this you've probably got
one of the best but sadly the weakest uh
Police Service that we've ever had but
they're the most tolerant we've ever had
as well and I'm afraid tolerance
sometimes hasn't worked well in their
favor interesting stuff I want to bring
in Victor to this now he's been
listening in and Victor you're very
involved of diverting inclusion in a
police force you're listening to those
comments from uh Norman now do you agree
no I don't agree uh there are far too
many things
that I don't agree with not what
normally just said and I'd like to start
before I go on I serve 35 years in the
Police Service
but also the rank of Chief
superintendent and served in some of the
most challenging places how the
privilege to serve in some of the most
challenging places in London and I'm
proud to have been a police officer
let me start off by Norman saying he
doesn't see colors
I think you ought to I think every
single officer who polices any public
area should see color should see
difference should respect difference and
what we start saying we don't see color
we don't see difference that's where the
problem starts now so Mark has been very
clear that the police as an institution
that met as an organization should not
be linked to any causes but that's not
the same as an officer who has his or
her Authority Under the crowns the
Constable can't show empathy can't show
respect for people who may be suffering
or people who suffer or whose Community
have suffered
and Injustice that is very different
from actually having a political cause
and as a police officer one of the
things that you ought to have going on
the peeling principle that we're here is
to protect life first and foremost is to
be able to show empathy and I think it
is wrong to start quoting walk
um activities being walk about anything
and not being a public servant that
shows empathy and understanding and when
officers start doing that as individuals
as an organization we talk about the
good old days of the cop going back to
policing and and solving crime police
have never been particularly effective
in solving crimes without the public and
if we start saying that some of the
areas in which police face the greatest
challenges are those areas where people
with from different protected
characteristic lives if we can't make we
as an organization can't make contact
relationship build trust with them then
we're not going to get or the police are
not going to get the information that
they need to solve crime time to be
effective to be efficient and to earn
the trust of all Community Victor thank
you Norman I'll give you a chance to
respond shortly but want to bring Xavier
in on this listening in from across the
pond the Atlantic and the black lives
matter movement of course that started
that police taking the knee and many
other people as well what do you make of
the decision then to try and stop this
activity within police forces have you
I think it's a great decision please the
officers need to get back to basics stop
worrying about being woke and start
worrying about being strong because I've
been black for 26 years and I have great
relationships with a lot of Law
Enforcement Officers that's because they
don't view me as a skin color they view
me as a law-abiding citizen because
that's what I am and look I live in Los
Angeles California I don't even wear my
glasses in public anymore because I have
seen enough there is so much crime
across our nation because we have a
shortage of quality police officers to
protect our communities the reason we
have such a shortage is one that defund
the police movement and more more
significantly police officers are
treated like crap both by the public but
especially by their department heads and
that's only going to worsen if police
officers keep being inserted into
Political discussions So to avoid that
we need to police officers to be just
like most Professionals in the world and
hold the political views until they are
off the clock it's not a police
officer's job to enforce their opinions
it's a police officer's job to enforce
the law Norman there you go Xavier
agreeing with a lot there but Victor
also calling you out for not seeing
color
well Victor is doing exactly what we're
all concerned about he's saying that we
should look at black people and look at
them differently until and you know we
shouldn't I'm saying that we should
stand up and we should police all
communities without fear or favor and
one of the biggest criticisms against
the police nowadays and I was a police
officer for 31 years on a robbery scored
for six years is that the number of
black suspects or black people young men
particularly that are stopped in search
well when 73 74 of all Street robberies
murders and stabbings are committed by
young black men often on other black men
who is it that the police are meant to
be stopping 50 white people to satisfy
the black community and 50 of the black
community to satisfy the politicians and
the woke Brigade or if seven crimes out
of every ten of knife crime homicide gun
crime is committed by young black men
it's they that we should be targeting
and how how anybody can say that is
racist it's beyond me unless of course
you stop someone and the connotations of
your words or conduct are racist we have
to give a final word to Victor on that
victim
of time but give you an opportunity to
respond no of course Norman is talking
about a small part of London there are
people who commit knife crimes in other
parts of England they're not black
okay they're not 70 people who commit
offenses commit offenses because they
are committing offenses not because of
their color not because of the
nationality not because of protective
characteristics you should police
regardless and if you don't see color
you don't see difference you don't see
empathy you don't take into account that
black people as you just said Norman you
look at the stop and search data they're
disproportionately stopped and searched
wherever you go in the UK that saying as
an institution of policing black people
are criminogenic that is absolutely
wrong you need to see difference to
actually police difference I'm not
saying you should Mark out people given
privileged treatment but you should
understand that by seeing difference
then you stop stereotyping you stop
acts in a way that disadvantages them
that's policing without fear or favor
whether you're black white or male or
female the long and the short is the
majority of police officers do not get
do not get the support that they deserve
because the majority of honest
hard-working caring non-violent
non-racist but unfortunately the
narrative tells everyone difference I'm
here to speak up for the front line tens
of thousands of honest men and women
that are called racist after or
misogynistics
majority of police officers are not car
races the majority of police officers do
a good job there's a handful of police
officers who behave badly let's talk
about those officers dealing with those
officers lest or categorize
1998 99 of police officers men and women
who do fantastic jobs who see color who
see difference who show empathy who are
the best of public servants
agree on that point let's end on that
agreement unfortunately straight out of
time but we do want to get all three of
you back to continue this conversation
it's been really interesting thanks all
three
uncensored next tonight the Spanish
football kiss Scandal lingers on now
some are saying it's part of an anti-man
agenda are they right will debate
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
coming up on the talk protests and
vandalism on the first day of Sadiq
Khan's Euler's expansion the air traffic
control chaos is now expected to last
until Friday with abandoned passengers
forced to sleep in airports when the
fire service is banned from using the
word firemen we'll explain why at nine
[Music]
welcome back to Onsen so joined Now by
my pack the political journalist Ava
Santina and talk TV presenter Richard
Tice rejoins us after a spicy starts at
the show Richard I love disagreeing with
you
um let's have some more disagreement
then and this time about Notting Hill
Carnival a debate that comes around
every August when it happens
um because there are instances of
violence when it happens in fact we were
just talking about policing it's a
challenging time for police officers in
the capital but it necessarily reignites
this debate every year about whether it
should be canceled or moved somewhere
else entirely but of course there's a
huge cultural heritage point about
having it in London Ava well I just
think that the argument is very simple
there were two million people there so
obviously there are going to be some
arrests when you look back at the London
Olympics there were 250 people arrested
last year there were 2 000 football fans
arrested and in the police itself the
police there were 90 people arrested
last year now so what does that mean if
you're going to get rid of Notting Hill
Carnival because you're worried about
arrest well then we can't host the
Olympics again we're going to have to
disband the Metropolitan Police and we
also can't host football matches I just
think it's a silly comparison well I
think actually what we could almost
agree on this maybe what we should do is
say it's so popular so many londoners
and people love it but actually it is
quite dangerous it's completely
uncontrolled within those very tight
streets maybe what they should do is try
it for a year or two perhaps in the Hyde
Park so you can still get that wonderful
Carnival atmosphere but in a slightly
safer environment that's easier to
Steward easier to police and therefore I
suspect I hope would be a lot less
dangerous you would lose all of the
culture of it because the point is it's
got to be honest
wonderful floats the passion the love
have you have you been Richard to the
Notting Hill Carnival I was worried
you'd ask me that no the honest answer
is no but I'm not sure I'm not sure it's
my gig but I know it is a great gig for
many many as you say millions of people
but the police officers they dread it
because they know it's dangerous they
know it's difficult to police they know
it's going to kick off at the back end
of course but but you've got to be able
to try if something's really dangerous
maybe say should we try something else
see if that works for a year and learn
from it and if it doesn't work try
something else no more football matches
in central London I think we've solved
it talk your football matches let's talk
about the Spanish kiss Scandal the story
that's not going away and you know
Spanish prosecutors have now launched a
sexual assault investigation to Luis
rubialis about the kiss and Jenny Mercer
I feel like we've gone at this from 15
different angles over the last few days
across the media but one we wanted to
run by was this video from the weekend
this is Irish jockey Sean karane being
kissed by female owner of live in the
dream Jolene she ran into the sort of
enclosure smacked a kiss on him I mean
he looks pretty happy about it but of
course she's seizing his head doing it
and it did raise the question what's so
different Ava yeah I mean I don't know
why she's done that maybe yeah I don't
know maybe she's having a really good
time and it's a bit ill-advised isn't it
but look I think there's something to do
with the power Dynamic right so what was
going on at that football match you know
they've just won the World Cup this is a
man who is so powerful and so important
and is now defining that This Woman's
career in a way that is it shouldn't be
nice he's brought football in Spain into
disrepute and he's turned a massive
success for women's football in Spain
and for Spanish football at a broader
level he's just destroyed it all he's
ruined it and he hasn't even had the
mouse the courage to do the decent thing
so look I didn't mean it but he hasn't
apologized he's just he's actually
trebled and quadrupled down and I think
it's a catastrophe for Spanish football
absolutely yeah it says a lot about the
court of public opinion as well because
I think most people I say 95 of people
can appreciate the sort of stupid thing
to do and he should go for it and then
there's that small minority of men
who've come out to defend him and it's
sort of given a good red flag to every
woman out there like these are the men
to stay away from do you think there is
you mentioned power Dynamic Ava I'll dig
into it just a little bit deeper do you
think there it's a difference when a
woman plants an unwanted kiss on a man
no I don't look I don't know I think in
this scenario it it doesn't it doesn't
seem it seems a bit light-hearted and a
bit fun and he looked to enjoy it but
look who am I I'm not him and I don't
know how he felt about it I just think
the best advice I could give is probably
don't kiss someone unless they've
consented Richard is there such a thing
as an unwanted Kiss from a woman if
you're a man I'm not sure there is no
I speak for myself
okay where are we going but I just had
to sense check that because I think that
is I mean we're laughing about it but of
course it is serious uh I think for
women it's very different there's a lot
of unwanted sort of attention from men
for men there is a slightly different
Dynamic going the power Dynamic it is
different but but if you've got it wrong
just just admit it I mean people much
prefer you say I'm really sorry we
messed up got this one wrong and but
it's become an absolute disaster for the
whole relationship you've got the whole
football team has quit For Heaven's Sake
and completely overshadowed that Amazing
World Cup win as well that is it from us
here in the studio whatever you're up to
make sure it's uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think there's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
tool it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appear
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job resonates with people
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]